Peter King is going to wrap us up we're
having actual Hall of Famer wrapping us
up here as opposed to they gave me a
bust here Peter for my new show I don't
know if it's worthy I don't know if it's
worthy of it but that's why I got to
have you on at least class this place up
a little bit thanks for joining me well
I certainly am worthy rich but it's it's
nice of you to remind me of that please
you you're the best man um so what do
you think is the deal with San Francisco
what's going on we had Jed York
yesterday saying it's on category its
credit courting not true that Jim
Harbaugh is out no matter what at the
end of the season oh but but there's got
to be some smoking around if there's no
fire correct I think there's certainly
some smoke I mean you know you don't
hear out the Cleveland Browns a year ago
if there's not some smoke you don't
basically get a little bit more than a
year away from the end of his contract
with the realization that you probably
are not going to be able at least it
looks like now you're not going to be
able to get an extension done before his
lame duck year um a in and look I think
it's sensible for all parties that you
know that it's not a big deal now just
because you're playing football now so
Jed York I think rightfully so is saying
you know everybody cool your jets it's
absolutely not true that he's definitely
gone or whatever it is he said on your
show yes and I buy that and I also buy
that look Jed York certainly doesn't
want to make Jim Harbaugh the
highest-paid coach and football before
he wins a super bowl so what if he wins
a super bowl this year I think he wins a
super bowl they offer him a boatload of
money and he'd stay so I don't think
it's definite that he's gone but i would
say that i was going to vegas and had to
bet one side or the other i would bet
that this is his last
year yeah he did say that Jed York did
say that hehe hope season the worst
negotiating position ever which would
mean obviously the sample went what are
you what do you make of Russell Wilson's
performance on Monday night and in terms
of placing himself in the MVP
conversation well rich that that game
and especially the end of that game
really convinced me that he's he's a
different quarterback from all the other
quarterbacks in that I don't necessarily
want to know his deadline I want to know
his efficiency I want to know his you
know how he converts third downs I want
to know how he is in the red zone and I
want to know how he makes his team
better and I mean after the play where
he pirouettes away from Ryan Kerrigan
and lost that floater the kind of folly
floater to Marshawn Lynch and Lynch runs
for 25 or 30 yards I mean I'm I'm just I
just said to myself okay this guy he's
different he's just totally different
and you know I don't care if he throws
for 200 yards a game or whatever and
eaten and he doesn't throw for all the
touchdowns or anything like that the guy
is one of the best quarterbacks in
football how many among the top I mean
how many are there five six seven I
don't know but whatever the list is
Russell Wilson has to be in that list
and they have the Dallas Cowboys coming
into their house this week one of the
marquee games obviously for week number
six and the Cowboys at four and one
running the football more than anything
else DeMarco Murray is 210 yards clear
of anybody else in the running the
department of rushing yards department
coming into this game and jerry jones
this past week said that he wanted to
see his touches limited he wanted to see
more touches from the backups and both
marshall faulk and even Michael Irvin on
Sunday game day morning took that to
mean that Jerry
is already looking at the contract
that's looming where do you stand on
this issue Peter no Jer I mean he might
be looking at the contract but well
there's a couple things Michael Irvin
should know this Jerry pays his stars
and he's going to pay DeMarco Murray but
here's the whole thing that they're
looking at bridge you know last year he
carried the ball 217 times this guy has
had three fairly significant injury to
significant injuries in his three
previous seasons in the NFL why in the
world would you want to make them carry
it 400 times I understand that
everything's working great and and it is
working great but you know come on I
mean if you think that that DeMarco
Murray can average 26 carries a game
which is what he's averaging right now
you think he can average 26 carries a
game after last year basically running
the ball about 15 times a game and
getting hurt III think it's I think it
Jerry and Jason Garrity said the same
thing yesterday I wrote it this morning
that we have to um you know we have to
look for other ways and other guys to
help us do this i mean there's nobody in
the NFL right now he's got more than 94
carries i think except for him and he's
got 130 mmm so let's be realistic about
what you want to do with DeMarco Murray
what about the Patriots do we do we
think that they're on the they moved on
to Cincinnati and then on to what we
expect them to be or there's more bumps
in the road still to come well there's
going to be some more bumps in the road
they played that game like with some
combination of a super bowl in the
seventh game of a World Series I mean I
don't recall rich Tom Brady being as
intensely involved in every aspect of
the game as he was in that game on
Sunday night and I've just not seen him
that involved in in in everything as he
was in that game and I think if you
compare that to what you saw Monday
night against Kansas City
you know a week ago when he was
absolutely aloof and almost he appeared
to be like depressed yes in that game I
mean he was just different i'll tell you
what what oh i see the difference right
now i I think he understands that now
that tim wright who's in his third
offense in the last 16 months remember
you had to learn two of them in tampa
one his rookie year and one when Jeff
Tedford came in and then he's got to
come to New England at the end of august
and learn josh mcdaniels offense and so
look he he really had a learning curve
that he had to learn in like a month now
he's up to speed pretty much Gronkowski
who had played only fifty percent of the
snaps the first month now I think played
about 70 or so a percent of the snaps on
Sunday he's a little more ready Brandon
LaFell is getting to know Tom Brady a
little better so as long as that happens
and as long as their offensive line
continues to mature a rookie like Bryan
stork in the middle he's getting more
used to this offense by the week I think
they're still going to win the division
they are going to have some rocky
moments but I think you're going to see
them throw to the tight end and start to
use start to use Tim right the way they
used to use Aaron Hernandez not as good
as Hernandez but I think you're going to
see him used in that vein someone thanks
Peter appreciate you joining me on one
of my inaugural shows i hope to get you
back on very soon all of us reach thank
you you bet that's Peter King the mmqb
calm also on NBC